we'll take a question so what did you
say over that the United States of
America okay
hey what did you say there was there was
a lady's voices shout out something yeah
mailmen okay I'm gonna combine that male
men in the United States of America the
United States of America Melman
specifically mailmen you being gender
specific there no no you said why you
called a male man then I don't walk out
how see a nice there you go good morning
mailman that seems pointed good day
letter person that's what I call them
the United States of America Melman
someone over here said so what'd you say
Popeyes I mean it wasn't that but that's
amazing Popeyes chicken sandwich United
States of America mailmen let's get some
water to get three more nights as in
with the K and the start right yeah cool
cool nights do you want have a
particular aspect of nights or night
[ __ ] you want me to delve into I don't
know why I'm posing like this just yeah
give me more
once again I'm British
no no just no I didn't think it would be
this in-depth brisance you were thinking
King Arthur let me what like the knights
of the round table yeah that's fair you
just couldn't remember what shape the
table was Knights at the table yeah
dodecahedron table that'd be a polygon
wouldn't it one it is cool
so King Arthur and the knights of the
round table USA mailmen popeyes chicken
sandwich well before you can do with
that just delay D the badges oral
hygiene it's important guys y'all y'all
gotta floss Cole oral hygiene I like
that and what was that the Queen does
Vegas I mean uh well I thought you'd go
for that no the Queen does Vegas I was
just like we [ __ ] about your 94 year old
woman look for some reason is in charge
I like that
what do you say when you were growing up
in India you said god save the queen
nice treason
[ __ ] you blasphemer this is I'm really
sorry for what we did to your country
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
mean no you didn't deserve it Wow
just I was gonna yeah that's that's
amazing Jesus we're starting a debate
here no one deserved that well we got
cricket yes but it's not worth it
so okay so let's just collect all these
together so the Queen does Vegas popeyes
chicken sandwich
you chose night the round table us male
men and what was a final one oral
hygiene thank you you might need to
remind me because literally in my head
now just being like did you really just
do that Cricket in India joke Chris you
should be ashamed of yourself that's me
on Twitter tomorrow right here we go a
freestyle rap made up entirely on the
spot based entirely on those suggestions
and don't worry it's not anywhere near
as atrociously embarrassingly bad as you
are expecting a twenty nine-year-old
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be so we should have done a sound
check but [ __ ] it let's drop that [ __ ]
unless somehow we do I'm excited I'm
excited even though you guys just so
angry about
you can pop that
[Music]
everyone just sits I'll be like what the
[ __ ] is about to happen
people wondering what the [ __ ] happens
next let me look at on the window
there's the USPS not the UPS or the
FedEx I just go the guys that deliver
wind rain or snow are almost wish their
letters round here I've got my letter
round when I am the postman everybody
comes around to me there's no better
slipping those letters who washes in the
jaws here never forget they deliver all
week every time the day apart from
holidays like Labor Day you'll be sad
there yeah we cheer round bowls too
why on this day don't we get that post
Nome a little tail yeah I got plan you
need XY chromosomes be a man apparently
if there's no ladies can do it they've
got too much tits for the dog to chew
through it the dog runs down digit bites
in their boobies those are so horrible
here I want to do these I'm in Vegas
with my dream team I'm hung over on the
right side is the queen your majesty
did you win the gamble in I'm in the
casino just gambling in a lei
me in the mana she got a little talky so
she gets on it the slot machine she
pulls the one-armed bandit 777 year it's
just like she's landed getting money
which is like whoo now I don't need
money cuz I own the crown jewels a
sapphire it's right in here
I'm sorry that we stole it from India we
did yeah miss Tyra Calcutta I've got a
fist bump from a man smooth like butter
sorry smooth like geez that's the
clarified one here I might be Jeremih by
oh my groceries out in Mumbai a move on
now yeah watch me try a spin a legend
I'm selling you're a favor part of the
king with the Knights at the table why
did he find the one with the round shape
he wanted to make sure there's no
mistake people drumming over there
hidden on the rims plus a lot of win
event making eyes at him if you don't
know the names of the characters sorry
but I'm gonna keep going yet to telling
that story Lancelot he was the brave it
won then you got ladies Sherlock in the
lane okay we'll move on cause no one's
ever studied it but that's okay
your breath smell [ __ ] oh no I need to
give them all will relief get a little
brush take the plaque right out of my
teeth I go there to the dentist
in Sciences and Kane as you know I'm
gonna show you
I'd like to scrape my tongue like a boss
I use the mouthwash and the dental floss
every single day
yeah I do a little tap that's a floss -
can't do it around my implant and not
beat up when I was a young boy I was
working hard in the kitchen employed not
a love Donald who you might be surprised
I was in the UK but still were to pop
eyes I was amazing
yeah I'm gonna hand it survey up fresh
like a fried chicken sandwich everybody
here today we're like hip for a [ __ ]
chick-fil-a they are bunch of homophobes
and we've got the finger licking you go
to Popeyes they be strong with the
chicken or sadly though or thereabout
like here the most branch job that sold
the [ __ ] out yet
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]